Tu armed groups gathering in mali's
northern city of
kidal preparing for a confrontation with
malan soldiers and Russian fighters
heading their way un peacekeepers known
as minisa are leaving the city saying
there is no peace for them to
keep the presence of the UN peacekeepers
is extremely important for this city in
addition to their security Mission they
also provide jobs for many of kid's
young people and when they leave these
young people will migrate or join armed
movements the conflict between armed
groups and the Malian Army has caused
insecurity and harmed civilians who have
nothing to do with it these touring
Fighters are celebrating after shooting
down an army aircraft and attacking a
malan military
base we launched the attack at 3:00 and
by 4:00 we had taken control of two
malan Army Camps and the National Guard
base Long Live azawad God is great
they say the operation is in retaliation
for attacks by Russian Fighters and the
Malian Army this appears to spell the
end of the 2015 peace agreement and the
beginning of a long and violent
confrontation with no end in sight
Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer